all right all right so i've got i've got
this idea for a show i've got this idea
for a show we've got a mother
son mother son queen egg queen
egg okay egg sings i want to break free
because it's queen that's my show it's a
queen
hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand line waifu and we're
going to spend a lot of time discussing
strange bugs because it's the chimera
and arc of hunter hunter and there are
so many songs stuck in my head
help in missy moore feed me
all night long okay mother that's how
i'm seeing this queen now because she's
audrey too and seymour is just flying
dude bra skinner and that's at least two
different references i'm really proud
of myself because popular culture in me
don't tend to get on
right 78 what i don't understand is how
entire populations don't actually do
something if something frightening
happens to grab them if a bug grabbed me
i would fight because oh sweet jesus how
is it possible such a big bug exists i
tend to
run from bugs and i tend to react kill
bugs and that's i don't mean to react
kill but like
it's a bug and it's so gross there are
so many concepts deep and
psychologically based concepts
introduced in this episode that it
brings
up a lot of questions for me what is it
that dictates humanity and how do we
know it's there
for one thing a two meter tall ant woman
is questioning whether she has human
genes in her and the only reason she's
considering this is that she finds it
odd that
naming conventions are fascinating and
individualism is a concept that she
believes may not represent ant hood i
guess
do ants have an individual sense of
being apparently they do now
my first thought about all of this is
how does an ant queen get to be two
meters tall without human genetics what
else could they have
eaten and still look vaguely like an ant
but like
with kind of creepy pectoral boobies
where are the rest of her kind how did
she get to be two meters
and wash up entirely alone like how do
you like how how is that
not something that's come up before why
have we not heard about this being an
issue
what incredible coincidence that the
place she washes up
is one with absolutely no technology to
deal with it apparently unless the king
hears about it
and decides that he's the only one
allowed to have technology i also love
that the immediate thought by this new
bug race is that the humans are a
resistance force
which makes sense when you consider that
actually all their previous experiences
with it were bug people just
taking farmers and villagers and
children i wonder what this ant king and
his guards will look like we've got good
set up for hunters to become very
nutritional food
since the behavior of a kid came into
play in the sense that he remembers his
mum
and his deep convictions of care for his
sister it's not beyond reasoning that
if kite or the beast hunter guy from the
exam or ponzi whatever her name is get
eaten we'll end up with
hunter powerful creatures which probably
relate to the butterfly people
in the opening credits we're in a
situation where if they lose a battle
against these creatures
they just become one of the creatures
because why waste the food when you can
create more of you to create
more food like what you were it's a
strange situation to be in and i'm
rather intrigued to see where things go
from here and then we have that strange
new drug
sounds like tagashi's been doing some
learning what's weird about this show is
that tagashi decides to go darker with
every arc but his method of going darker
is just like
hey i'll just choose this other topic
that people don't like to
have anything to do with like i'll just
go more taboo ones that just don't often
come up in animation and
and you know what i'll manipulate people
using that i guess my problem is that
part of my job in daily life is actually
to pretty much
not be surprised by human behavior so
the taboo-ness of topics doesn't really
affect me all that much what i do find
interesting is the way that he engages
them and the way we respond or
are supposed to respond people who
assume hisoka as a paedophile come under
that category
and wherever it is we're going with drug
use or abuse and the lack of morals
around killing and eating children is
another one
there's a series of drop-off points for
this show where i can imagine there's
disengagement from
audience on particular moral lines and
that leaves people who enjoy flirting
with those lines
people who enjoy the psychology engaged
in discussing taboos like this
and those who are caught up enough in
the story that they're willing to just
ignore their general moral standpoint to
stick with it regardless
oh and there are those people who don't
think anywhere near this deeply about
any of it and continue to watch because
none of it seems particularly dark
it's only really when you question the
intensity and the themes of a show that
you can start to question how
what why and when these things were
being discussed and in the context of
people calling this
the dark ark dark ark dark dark
it's really hot say like it's a weird
thing to say
dark ark anyway in the context of people
calling this the dark ark i'm now
interested to hear your definition of
dark so please drop a comment below
and tell me why you'd call this content
in particular
dark beyond all this the idea that
there's any point to the kids running if
kite comes to harm seems strange
if jing has been keeping an eye on what
god does all this time and putting
things in place for gone to engage with
it stands to reason that jing would in
fact judge him for leaving kite behind
like his name gone is now tethered to
jing's mentee
even if jing doesn't actively care about
kite beyond having someone who can do
things for him
gon has to protect that connection to
his father kilwa's assertion that he's
all about impulse is actually laughable
and i did
laugh out loud legitimately at that
thing that he said
because he likes to put forethought into
almost literally every action but he's
right about one thing
gone would do what is necessary in the
moment so there's not much point to him
steaming about it now
speaking of which i'm ready to steam
over the next episode so let's get into
it
episode 79 which i'm going to call the
development of a society
important things need names so the queen
is going to name the guards herself
which is
something of significance so i guess
they don't get to be creative with the
names they decide for themselves
and that's a whole new interesting
scenario that tagashi's cooked up here
really we're watching the quick
development of a new society with the
people beginning to realize that they
are what they eat
they've grown from hunting and gathering
to questioning food quality standards
ethical standpoints on which they should
be left to grow and ripen whether food
should be free range or bread for
slaughter and whether the queen is
willing to give time to that
it's all actually quite an interesting
experiment when you think about it
and it seems that they've developed
faster than like you know
the real life human race so it's really
interesting
i mean it's awful awful awful that
people are dying of course but we went
through that situation last dark where
the people in what they thought was a
game with just digital people turned out
to be
likely real people on an island playing
out some psychopaths sick fantasy
when speaking of jing gon and his
multiplied hunters
because hunter hunter hunter squared
whatever this thing's called they're on
their way to deal with the situation
before it gets too late it's already too
late they had to leave their caricatured
asian friend behind but they have the
caricatured black friends so
we know he's going to be first to die a
winkity wink
they're very clearly on an island where
no future technology is allowed and i'm
confused as to how they survive given
even the age of copper bronze and steel
weren't inherently bad i mean even the
era we live in now isn't inherently bad
especially since there's new technology
anyway let's stop that
it's a very strange situation that this
crew have brought upon themselves it's
interesting that they don't care about
the death of their own people
how do you govern no one why someone
would want to live there
with that understanding i don't
understand especially since the people
in charge wouldn't live to those
standards either it's almost like the
guy on the door has just bred these
villagers for the purpose they're being
used for now and you know what tagashi
that would make sense i hear you they've
trained and raised people in a space
where they're not able to fight the
situation they find themselves in now
a place where a giant ant queen can
feast on their people who are not
able to communicate with the outside
world and when they are taken away they
don't fight because of course if a
freakishly large bug with a human face
comes and takes you away
that must be natural selection and the
development of this new species means
that now humans who i notice in the
artwork
especially when they're being carried
away are all just shaded around the eyes
presumably to dehumanize them for us so
we don't consider their fate
are considered livestock and should be
domesticated as
pets which is kind of cute it's kind of
like that thing where elephants think
that we
actually are kind of cute the cute part
of their brains get activated when they
see us just wandering around so
maybe elephants should be our overlords
my biggest question at the moment the
one i truly don't understand and that
seems absurd to me in all of this
is where did the koala that spits water
bullets at people
where did he get his suit where did he
get his suit like i don't care about the
water bullets
the water bullets aren't the problem the
water bullets i understand
where did he get the suit in a place
like this where no one can
have anything man-made in a place like
this where no one even realistically has
the ability to make something that clean
cut
and even if they could it couldn't be
brought in where did he get that suit is
he
even part bug where's the bug part since
when were koalas part of this ecosystem
how does a marsupial like this live in
that environment i understand our
friendly drop bears look really evil
and his whatever he's doing to people is
actually kind of cool
but what's going on here he seems about
to start his own secret
service mafia situation and defect to
the other side then defect back and it
turns out he was like a double triple
quadruple agent
and there are a few oddities like this
for me why would the queen ant rub her
stomach in excitement about the king
she's going to have when
she has an abdomen and the king ant
won't be live born
she's an egg layer that's what all those
green things are ants aren't
mammals like they don't have live young
and they don't i just
um also they're in giant trees that are
carved out to be the limits of land what
where is their power coming from where
is the there are so many issues with
this episode there are so many issues
with this society how are they doing
cavity searches with mri and x-ray
how is it possible to be so hypocritical
i have so many more
issues with the political structure that
enables this behavior than the
up-and-coming bug overlords coming to
eat their way to victory
maybe the bugs are the better options
and maybe that's the point to gash he's
trying to make i don't know
i'm just angry at this political
structure that to me
is the dark side of this arc that all
these bugs can be developing at such a
rapid pace and and becoming such
fully fledged and and rounded out
creatures while the humans have been
forcibly pushed back in time and
stripped of time-appropriate materials
oh and these bugs their name choices for
themselves is actually kind of adorable
if i'm honest how come we've seen
the brother come on out but not the
sister what happened to her there's a
bit of a skew going on where we see
certain kinds of personalities surviving
through death and into the bug they
become
why is it that some of these bugs are
wearing clothes are the clothes are part
of their actual biology
just wait does the koala guy like
this koala dude is that just fur does
the queen mind that he's just like got
suit fur
it's such a strange situation for these
bugs though few of them actually look
like bugs at this point when do they
stop being bugs and just start being a
community with
similar genetics as my notes say cult
peggy chitu zazen zaizan
zarzines ah i can only read or listen i
don't do both we don't want to encourage
too much individuality say the human bug
creatures with no doubles
can they breed among them no they
shouldn't be able to and
that's not how it works and can the
queen have more babies i mean she will
have more babies but will she be trying
to have
more babies with the king oh yay more
taboo
how how does propagation continue in
this ecosystem okay i don't really want
to think about it so that's it
from me if you enjoyed or found this
delve into the creepiness of the
beginning of this arc enjoyable hit like
subscribe and check out videos here here
and maybe here and you know what after
all this talk of food i feel kind of
hungry so i think it's lunch time
i have a cucumber it's tasty